لاول مره خصم لترومب تغادر المحكمه
بابتسامه عريضه بعد ان اقرت المحكمه سخاء
فاقم طالب دفاعها جين كارول تحصلت على
تعويض بقيمه خمسه ملايين دولار على ما حصل
قبل 27 عاما
ولم تعد تذكرها كوابيسه الانتخابيه الا ان
كارول اقنعت القضاء بان التداعياتها دمرت
مسارها المهني بعد ان سخر انتقام
الملياردير كلما يملك من اجل الحط من
سمعتها لتترك الكاتبه الصاعده تصارع
لوحدها
مطارده الساحرات لتشامب لم تعد مجرد فضائح
بل تحولت الى جزء من سيره المترشح الذي
يتجاوز قضيه حتى تطفو واقصه اخرى لسطح
هي فرص لاعدائه السياسيين الا ان تصدر
عناوين الجرائد السفر في كل مره
يكتسب من المناعه ما يجعل الفضائح تتحول
الى مجرد حادثه ان لم تخدم حملته
الانتخابيه فلن تمنع عنه احلام العوده
للبيت الابيض اتهام تشوم بشراء صمت ممثله
اباحيه باموال مشبوهه لم يزل الضباب عن
الناخبين بين انتخاب ضحيه ام معاقبه مذنب
قبل ان تنجح اهداهن في ادانه تشومب لاول
مره تروم لم يتذكر الحادثه او ربما ضاع
اسمها وسط الكثيرات ليثبت عجزه عن التصالح
مع الناخبات والتي لم يحصد الا اربعه
واربعين في المئه من اصواتهن في
الانتخابات التي فاز بها النساء تحولن
لتحدي انتخابي قائم بذاته
الا ان ترومب يتسلح بانصار لا يتاثرون
بفضيحه ولا ادانه لكن اصواتهم وحدها لا
تكفي ويتوجب عليه اقناع اصوات جديده
والبدايه من حزبه
جمهوريون كثر باتوا يطالبون بمترشح جديد
خوفا من ان يستغل الشامبو انصاره الحزب في
مرحله اولى قبل ان يصيروا يوما ما اكبر من
الحزب نفسه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات